Lions have them hippos have them and
even you and I have them canines those
long pointy front teeth they're actually
the longest teeth in the human mouth so
what are these long sharp teeth doing
among our short stubby ones well
contrary to popular belief it's not for
tearing and ripping meat the real reason
is actually much more romantic than that
[Music]
human men today have 10 percent longer
canines than women and this difference
isn't unique to our species our close
relatives gorillas have it as well to an
even larger extent males canines are
twice as long as females that's because
in gorilla society males compete for
exclusive mating rights to the entire
female troop and the male with the
longest most intimidating set of fangs
usually wins over time gorillas have
evolved increasingly longer canines but
when it comes to humans our teeth took a
different evolutionary path our canines
have actually become shorter over time
just look at the canines on the first
human are two Pythias ramidus or
Australopithecus Anna menses versus
modern humans in fact our canines today
are the shortest they've ever been and
the difference between male and female
canines got less pronounced as well
that's because unlike modern gorillas
who take after our shared ancient
ancestors human men eventually stopped
fighting with their teeth somewhere
along the way now scientists aren't
entirely sure why this happened but one
possibility is that our babies grew
increasingly defenseless so males had to
spend more time on childcare and less
time on winning a mate as a result all
that's left in our mouths today is the
memory of a more slobbery method of one
nothing our peers that's right those
canines you carry around today aren't
particularly useful for one thing
they're not long enough to grab and hold
on to pray the way Lions use them and
they're not big enough to intimidate
predators or rivals the way hippos use
them instead they help us buy into food
that's it turns out evolution isn't
always useful but while the truth about
our canines might be disappointing those
teeth are still pretty amazing because
anthropologists use canines size and
shape to help track when human-like
ancestors evolved so in a way our tiny
canines make us who we are